mehr als 200 Tage Krieg in und gegen die
Ukraine aufhorchen am Wochenende
Geländegewinne gegen die Russen im Osten
im Moskau spricht von einer
Umgruppierung seiner Truppen Kiew sagt
insgesamt 6.000 Quadratkilometer habe
man zurückerobert Optimisten sehen den
Krieg an einem Wendepunkt was gilt nun
unser Thema heute am Wendepunkt der
Krieg gegen die Ukraine
[Musik]
Phoenix Runde
willkommen meine Damen und Herren zur
phönixsrunde ich darf Ihnen unsere Gäste
vorstellen zu meiner Rechten Daniel
brößler leitender Redakteur in der
parlamentsredaktion der Süddeutschen
Zeitung hier in Berlin mit dem Fokus
Kanzleramt der war auch Korrespondent in
Moskau und in Brüssel gekommen herzlich
Willkommen an Natalia prijonicka sie ist
Politikwissenschaftlerin und
Mitbegründerin der Allianz ukrainischer
Organisationen willkommen Hansi und zu
meiner Rechten
Ralf Thiele Militär Experte Oberst und
er ist Vorsitzender der politischen
militärischen Gesellschaft hier in
Berlin und last but not least Lars
pohlmeier er ist Arzt und Vorsitzender
der deutschlandsektion der Organisation
IPPNW internationale Ärzte für die
Verhütung des Atomkriegs und mit einer
Russin verheiratet wir uns verraten hat
also das sind unsere Gäste meine Damen
und Herren vorab vielleicht eine
Bemerkung keiner hier im Raum von uns
kann stabil sagen ob kommunizierte
Fakten wirklich Fakten sind das wollen
wir vorausschicken um sauber jetzt zu
diskutieren und wir beginnen gleich mit
jemandem der das militärische sehr gut
überblicken kann nämlich mit Ralf Thiele
der Wendepunkt so ist es von manchen
getitelt worden ihre Einschätzung der
militärischen Lage jetzt in der Ukraine
was war das am Wochenende war das jetzt
ein Wendepunkt oder einfach nur ein
Warnschuss gegen die russischen Truppen
ich beginne mit einem Paukenschlag
tatsächlich denn das war eine
überraschende mutige kluge gut
vorbereitete Aktion die zu einem
Durchbruch in der Front geführt hat man
wird jetzt im Nachgang sehen wie sich
das auswirkt tendenziell kann man nach
ein paar Tagen sagen 1000
Quadratkilometer 2 3000 jetzt 6.000
Quadratkilometer offensichtlich gewinnt
die Offensive Raum offensichtlich ziehen
sich die Russen zurück zum Teil
unkoordiniert und wilder Flucht zum aber
auch koordiniert man wird jetzt sehen
müssen wie das sich weiterentwickelt in
jedem Fall ist das sicherlich eine der
wichtigsten Aktionen seit der Abwehr des
Angriffs der Russen auf Kiew die
nachhaltig das ganze ist werden wir im
Laufe der Sendung diskutieren vielen
Dank für ihre erste Einschätzung Frau
prieren wenn wir auf die Stimmung in der
Ukraine jetzt schauen natürlich die
Bevölkerung verfolgt alles ganz intensiv
was lösen diese Erfolge der ukrainischen
Armee bei ihren Landsleuten aus was
hören sie Menschen in Ukraine freuen
sich natürlich sehr über die Erfolge der
ukrainischen Armee und das diese
Stimmung überträgt sich natürlich in die
ganze Welt Menschen die die Ukraine
unterstützen verfolgen die Nachrichten
und natürlich nach der Verteidigung von
KEF nach der Befreiung von
Schlangeninsel ist es jetzt auch mit
einer der größten Erfolge die gegen
Offensive der ukrainischen Armee brachte
und Herr Brüsseler gerade dieser Erfolg
bringt Deutschland jetzt noch mal ganz
gewaltig in die Klemme denn die Stufe
nach mehr Waffenlieferungen werden
lauter die Ampel ist mehr oder weniger
uneins darüber inwieweit muss
Bundeskanzler Scholz eigentlich seine
bisherige Linie korrigieren ja ich
glaube dass das tatsächlich ein
entscheidender Punkt ist in insofern
tatsächlich auch ein Wendepunkt weil
eine Prämisse des Kanzlers sich
zumindest nicht als ganz richtig
herausgestellt hat die Prämisse dass die
Ukraine jetzt zu einem weiteren starken
zu weiterer starke stärker militärischer
Gegenwehr eben nicht in der Lage sein
würde und dass sich eigentlich die Front
festsetzen würde jetzt sehen wir dass es
tatsächlich
ukrainischerseits die Möglichkeit gibt
Territorium zurückzuobern das verändert
eben auch die militärische Lage und auch
die Frage welche Waffen könnten jetzt
eventuell in dieser Situation helfen
insofern ist es eine neue Perspektive
der Druck aus Kiew in dem Zug jeden Tag
eben auch Panzer zu liefern Kampfpanzer
die zumindest aus ukrainische
Perspektive die Lage noch einmal
deutlich verändern können darauf was
Deutschland aus dieser Situation macht
kommen wir auch im Laufe des Sendung
noch mal zurück aber es bringt uns jetzt
noch einmal diese Grundfrage Diplomatie
statt Waffen bringt uns jetzt auch zu
das pohlmeyer Ihre Organisation die sich
halt eine Friedensorganisation versteht
hat bislang gesagt keine
Waffenlieferungen das unterstützen wir
nicht bleibt das ihre Linie oder nach
dem Erfolg vom Wochenende denken sie um
also wenn man präzise muss man sagen
meine Organisation hat gesagt mehr
Diplomatie statt mehr Waffen ich glaube
die letzte Gretchenfrage haben wir für
uns auch offen gelassen vor dem
Hintergrund der
das Recht ist der Verteilung der Ukraine
das denke ich ist noch mal was anderes
und dieses dieses dieser Ansatz bleibt
aus meiner Sicht vollkommen bestehen
wir wissen nicht genau was das jetzt
bedeutet militären Erfolge ich als Arzt
unten am wenigsten aber die Grundfragen
und die die Grundwahrheiten das ist eine
diplomatische Lösung geben muss dass wir
alles tun müssen und vielleicht auch
mehr tun müssen um das zu erreichen und
das auch mehr diskutieren müssen dieser
Aspekt bleibt aus meiner Sicht weniger
Waffen der Diplomatie aber im Moment
haben wir überhaupt noch keinen
diplometischen Ansatz aber am Ende der
Sendung kann man sich ja vielleicht noch
auf dieser Option jetzt müssen wir noch
ein bisschen näher Einsteigen in den
Kriegsverlauf Herr Oberst ade Herr
Thiele
die ukrainischen Truppen sind
zahlenmäßig und in der Ausstattung der
russischen Armee unterlegen das haben
verschiedene Netzwerke mehr oder weniger
bestätigt in den Zahlen auf wenn wir
jetzt keine Zahlenspiele hier betreiben
wollen aber dieser Erfolg und dieser
Offensive hat ja jetzt doch noch mal ein
anderes Bild gezeichnet also welche
Rolle spielt die Unterstützung des
Westens dabei mit Gerät nicht mit Mann
und Gerät aber mit Gerät ich darf
vielleicht vorausschicken ich finde
diese Fokussierung allein auf die Waffen
auch etwas unterirdische in unserer
deutschen Debatte war das Thema viel
komplexer ist und das sehen Sie jetzt im
Grunde auch in meiner Antwort wenn man
schaut warum konnte die Ukraine damals
vor Kiew bestehen warum konnte sie jetzt
den Angriff machen dann liegt vieles zum
Beispiel im Weltraum
satellitenaufklärung Elon Musk der mit
seinem Satelliten die Ukraine befähigt
die drohen zu fliegen die Daten zu
übermitteln in die gefechtstände Ziele
ganz exakt anzupeilen also viele Dinge
haben überhaupt gar nichts mit Panzer zu
tun sind ganz ganz wichtig dass
überhaupt erstmal die Daten da sind die
Vorbereitung auch der Truppen man hört
das Truppen die jetzt eingesetzt wurden
vorher im Westen gut vorbereitet wurden
auf diese Aktion dass diese diese ganze
dieser ganze Ansatz gut vorbereitet
wurde also vieles ist sehr komplex und
sehr breit gefächert und deswegen
sollten wir uns irgendwann auch mal auf
den Weg machen
zu denken als nur über alte Panzer zu
sprechen also zumindest über Taktik
werden wir gleich noch auch in dieser
Moment sprechen und die Frage wie man
auch davon außen unterstützt werden kann
aber ich hatte gesagt dann Herr Brüssel
sie haben einige Zeit in Brüssel als
Korrespondent verbracht haben die
nato-intensiv beobachtet viele fragen
sich in diesen Tagen Generalsekretär das
deutenberg wo ist eigentlich die NATO
wenn es doch nach seinem wearing um ein
entscheidenden Moment in diesem Krieg
geht der hinato ist ja nicht
Kriegspartei und will auch nicht
Kriegspartei sein dass ist von Anfang an
klar gemacht worden allerdings sind alle
Staaten die sich in der NATO
zusammengeschlossen haben letztendlich
starten die die Ukraine unterstützen
deshalb glaube ich schon auch dass das
Wort des nato-generalsekretärs Gewicht
hat wenn er zum Beispiel
gefragt wird ist das Argument zutreffend
dass wir bestimmte Güter nicht liefern
könnten weil wir damit die eigene
Verteidigungsfähigkeit
Schwächen die bündnisverteidigung
eventuell nicht gewährleisten können
wenn er dann sagt als
Nato-Generalsekretär das wichtigste
zurzeit ist die Ukraine zu unterstützen
dann hat das würde ich sagen zumindest
Gewicht als Allianz greift die NATO
militärisch nicht ein das kann sie auch
nicht das erwartet glaube ich auch zur
Zeit niemand
Frau brehanistka nach dem Erfolg vom
Wochenende könnte man sagen und sie
haben ja Ihr Ohr an der Ukraine und bei
ihren Landsleuten könnte man sagen der
Wunsch nach Rückkehr der ja auch
verschiedentlich zumindest auch in den
ersten Wochen des Krieges stark geäußert
wurde könnte jetzt wieder hervortreten
was beobachten Sie was nehmen sie war
zu einem möchte ich sagen dass auch der
Beginn des Krieges oft misslich falsch
sortiert wird denn der Krieg in der
Ukraine seit 9 Jahren andauert und der
flächendeckende Angriff der jetzt seit
im 7 monat ist das ist eine andere
Geschichte die wir diskutieren und ich
denke das wäre sehr wichtig auch im
Hinterkopf zu behalten denn es erklärt
es gibt eine gewisse Kausalität in
diesen ganzen Verläufen des russischen
Krieges in der Ukraine
ich denke es ist nachvollziehbar dass
die ukrainische Armee und die Ukraine
erinnern sich sehr darüber freuen wenn
die Gebiete befreit werden deswegen
finde ich auch wie schon vorhin eingangs
meinte mit der Sprache ist es sehr
wichtig darauf zu achten wie wir das
sagen weil Zurückeroberung klingt
nachdem als ob es der Ukraine gar nicht
gehört hat und jetzt auf einmal erobert
dass die Ukraine in der Tat ist es
ja also ich denke es ist ein wichtiger
Hinweis dennoch ist es aus der Sicht der
Ukraine Ukrainerinnen wie wir das sagen
wenn wir das in deutschen Kreisen
diskutieren oder in Deutschland
diskutieren in internationalen Preisen
diskutieren ist es glaube ich wichtig
uns klar zu machen dass die Ukraine
nicht erobert in dem Sinne sondern das
Land verteidigt und auch die die
Regionen zurück
ja befreit befreit genau vielen Dank für
frei und die Freude ist natürlich sehr
groß und ich denke das ist auch sehr
wichtig zu verstehen dass es auch
wichtig ist zu sehen dass mit Hilfe und
Unterstützung die Ukraine auch in der
Lage ist das zu machen
es bringt uns jetzt noch einmal zu einer
weiteren Einschätzung und wir haben
keine russische Stimme am Tisch deswegen
nehmen wir eine Anleihe bei Herrn Thiele
der uns erklären muss was sozusagen die
Moskauer Lesart einer Umgruppierung
seiner Truppen jetzt zu bedeuten hat das
klingt ja schon verwegen es ist so nicht
Sprache mit Sprache kann man viel machen
ich darf vielleicht noch mal ein
bisschen zurückführen wir hatten eine
operative Pause vor ein paar Wochen so
etwas deutete schon eine Umgruppierung
an
die Ukraine hat eine Finte gelegt mit
ihrer Offensive die sie immer wieder für
den Süden anlegte und Russland hat diese
Gruppierung diese operative Pause damals
dafür genutzt viele Kräfte in den Süden
zu bringen und hat damit den Nordosten
ja kräfteärmer gemacht
was jetzt passieren muss
das hat eben der der Ukraine Chance
gegeben durchzubrechen das war klug
angelegt und klug vorbereitet was jetzt
Russland eigentlich machen müsste wäre
seine frontstabilisieren weit über 1.000
Kilometer man kann streiten 1200 1500
Kilometer wo nehmen Sie die Kräfte her
sind das diese neuen frischen Kräfte die
sie gerade angeworben haben und die noch
nichts können nimmt man noch wie soll
mal unverbrauchte Kräfte aus anderen
Regionen die man auch aus guten Gründen
dort lässt das ist für Putin alles sehr
schwer auch die Frage gibt er
gebietpreis und versucht es nicht mehr
zu verteidigen das ist jetzt das alles
verbirgt sich hinter diesem einfachen
Begriff umgruppieren er muss jetzt ganz
entscheidende Weichenstellung
vornehmen die übrigens auch seinen Kopf
betreffen können von daher denke ich mal
an ein wichtiger Moment und all das ist
Umgruppierung und eine fette legen wie
sie es formuliert haben durch die
ukrainischen Truppen macht man nicht
einfach so sondern weil man zum Beispiel
vom amerikanischen Geheimdienst beraten
wird wie man das eventuell anstellen
kann ja
okay es gibt
Ängste die viele Menschen haben Herr
pohlmeier und ich schau sie an das
Atomkraftwerk saporisha das größte in
Europa
von dem was sie hören wie gefährlich ist
die Situation wie das ist natürlich von
der Ferne sehr aber wir haben am
Wochenende gesehen reaktore die
runtergefahren werden dann wieder leicht
an den Strom dann wieder eine Insel
Lösung sind also wenn man das von außen
als nichtexperte sieht hat man doch den
Eindruck es ist gravierend
darf ich noch einen Satz sagen zur zu
ihrer Bemerkung weil natürlich die was
ist passiert in Russland gehört nicht
nur die militärische Umgruppierung
sondern wie ist die Psychologie in
Russland das was ich höre ist dass es
durch diesen ich sag mal sicherlich
Schock der der ukrainischen Gebiets
Gewinne da ein Innehalten gegeben hat
über das Wochenende auch in der
öffentlichen Debatte aber jetzt auch ein
Bestimmung des jetzt erst recht auch in
der Bevölkerung das sind ja auch alles
Aspekte die wir bedenken müssen und das
ist auch wichtig bei der Frage nach der
NATO weil das eine Extrem sie haben zu
Recht gesagt dass Teile auch dass die
NATO nicht Kriegspartei werden will so
dass es ja die Lesart aber es wird
natürlich anders wahrgenommen in
Russland und in diese Richtung zu gehen
das zu fragen und zu debattieren
öffentlich das kann natürlich auch in
die Eskalation die eine Eskalation
vorantreiben auf russischer Seite zurück
zum Atomkraftwerk
das größte Atomkraftwerk in Europa wir
erinnern uns alle an die an den Unfall
in Tschernobyl ist natürlich symbolhaft
für die für die Geiselhaft in der sich
die Ukraine und wir uns alle befinden
wenn es dort zu einem Beschuss kommt und
zur Freisetzung von Radioaktivität die
einmal natürlich eine Unbewohnbarkeit
von lokalen
Landstrichen aber auch weitergehende
Gebiete in Europa betreffen kann
gerade ja
gut ich nehme ihre Bemerkung über
sozusagen die innerrussische Psyche mal
mit wenn ich darf und bringe Daniel
brössler der in seinem journalistischen
Leben unter anderem einige Jahre auch in
Moskau verbracht hat als Korrespondent
auch zu Putins Amtszeiten bereits und
kombiniere das jetzt erstmal mit der
Frage was macht sozusagen
dieses jetzt mit mit Russland wir hören
von Kommunalpolitikern die langsam
aufstehen
das sind aber vereinzelte Punkte ist das
der Beginn von etwas kann man sich von
außen so weit Wagen das einzuschätzen es
ist natürlich von außen schwierig ich
finde die Lokalpolitiker die sich jetzt
äußern die Putin zum Rücktritt
auffordern mutig
ich würde dieses Phänomen aber nicht
überbewerten ich glaube das sind
insgesamt wenige für Putin gefährlicher
ist aus meiner Sicht die andere Seite
für Putin gefährliche sind jene die
nationalistisch denken die jetzt die
jetzt
enttäuscht sind die sage ich mal das
Druckbild das seit Monaten aufgebaut
wurde nicht mehr aufrechterhalten können
im russischen Fernsehen ist ein glaube
ich klar als Nationalist erkennen barer
Experte aufgetreten der der sagte wer
glaubt denn heute wer kann denn wirklich
glauben dass das was da jetzt passiert
planmäßig ist das ist vor sechs Monaten
den Plan gab dass wir so lange diesen
Krieg führen es wird auch schon von
Krieg gesprochen obwohl das ja eine
spezialoperation sein soll dass wir
sechs Monate lang diesen Krieg führen
und dann müssen wir uns aus dem Raum
Krake fluchtartig zurückziehen war das
wirklich der Plan
mit den Liberalen wird Putin zurzeit
leicht fertig die kann er nämlich
jederzeit wegsperren wenn er jetzt
anfängt die andere Seite weg zu sperren
wird es glaube ich schwierig das kann er
nicht machen das ist also tatsächlich
ein reales Problem dass er zurzeit hat
und das führt auch hin zu Frage was
passiert mit Putin wenn die militärische
Entwicklung eindeutig in Richtung
Niederlage geht das kann er sich nicht
leisten politisch wird er das
wahrscheinlich wird er das
wahrscheinlich nicht überleben und all
das was in Russland und in seiner
Öffentlichkeit stattfindet wird
natürlich auch sehr intensiv in der
Ukraine betrachtet unter diesen
schwierigen Bedingungen in denen die
Zivilbevölkerung dort jetzt leben muss
wie viel Zuversicht ist jetzt noch da
wir sind heute am Tag 202 dieses Krieges
in der neueren Zeitrechnung wenn ich mal
ihre Begrifflichkeit aufnehme
können Sie bitte noch mal formulieren
also wir sind am Tag 202 dieses Krieges
jetzt und die Frage ist auch wenn Sie
schauen sozusagen das Putin
möglicherweise jetzt von ukrainischer
Seite jetzt ein bisschen Gegenwind
bekommt die Frage ist wie viel
Zuversicht ist jetzt noch beim
ukrainischen Volk auch da dass dieser
Krieg bald endet natürlich hoffen wir
alle ich denke in unsere Runde in
Deutschland in der Ukraine auf dem
ganzen Welt das Russland mit dem Krieg
in der Ukraine bald aufhört denn es ist
auch verständlich also ich denke das ist
auch nicht diskutabel das wenn Russland
aufhören den Krieg zu führen gegen die
Ukraine dass wir dann kein Krieg in
Europa haben wenn die ukrainische Seite
aufhört zu schießen dann gibt es bald
keine Ukraine und ich denke das ist also
außer Frage wenn wir die Situation
bewerten Menschen induktive aber
Menschen auch in Europa auch also in
ganz Europa in der Ukraine in
Deutschland sind glaube ich folgende
sehr genau und
wünschen dass das die Ukraine also nicht
alle Menschen deswegen sitzen wir in
dieser Runde aber Menschen in Ukraine
wünschen sich die Unterstützung von
Deutschland die Unterstützung der
NATO-Staaten und die glaube das glaube
daran ist sehr stark und das zeigen auch
die neuesten Umfragen ja danke und alle
Politiker ukrainischer Seite tragen
diesen Wunsch sehr deutlich vor das
bringt uns jetzt doch einmal zu den
Waffenlieferungen Herr Thieles ich habe
das durchaus noch im Ohr sie haben das
eingangs gesagt wir sind in Deutschland
zu fokussiert auf die Zusage weitere
Waffenlieferungen und auch auf die Frage
ob das den Krieg entscheidet aber ich
frage jetzt mal anders wie notwendig
sind diese Waffenlieferungen um das was
jetzt an Rückeroberung stattgefunden hat
zu halten
ja hier stellt sich eben die Frage die
wir immer vermeiden unser Diskussion die
nach dem Zweck was machen wir eigentlich
im Grunde der Ukraine helfen sich zu
verteidigen ist noch eine sehr abstrakte
Formel in ein zwei Wochen Russland
rauszuwerfen sicherlich nicht das sehen
wir schon an dem Kriegsverlauf
tatsächlich stellen sich die Staaten im
Augenblick auf einen langen Krieg ein
und genau diesem Zweck die also auf ein
mehrjährigen Krieg ein und diesen Zweck
dient die eine Einrichtung von
Versorgungslinien Produktion von
Munition Ausbildung von ukrainischen
Kräften denn genau diese
Waffenlieferungen die heute kommen
nützen der Ukraine heute und morgen noch
nichts war das alles Zeit fressen wird
das heißt nicht dass die Ukraine nicht
heute und morgen dringend Waffen braucht
wenn man einfach schaut gerade da auf
der langen Front was da an Artillerie
Munition verschossen wird das ist ja ein
fürchterlicher artilleriekrieg bei denen
die Russen bis zu 60.000 geraden am Tag
verfeuern und der Ukraine nach dem
Wissen dass ich habe fünf bis
zehntausend Granaten am Tag zur
Verfügung stellen also wir haben ein
ganz großes unverhältnis und diese ganze
Logistik muss ja irgendwo herkommen das
und das ist eben jetzt ein Teil der
unter anderem in diesem Rammstein Format
das aufgelegt wurde die verschiedenen
Nationen sich
Verteidigungsministerium
sich jetzt miteinander abstimmen es gibt
auch in Stuttgart bei dem amerikanischen
European Command eine kleine Gruppe die
etwas macht was man sonst von der
Ukraine erwarten müsste nämlich
Kriegswirtschaft planen wir haben im
Grunde die Kriegswirtschaft die in der
Ukraine nicht stattfinden kann aufgrund
der ganzen Schädigungen Zerstörung
dieser stattgefunden haben ausgelagert
in den Westen und versuchen jetzt all
das von an Logistik zu erbringen ist an
Unterstützungsleistung zu koordinieren
und vorzubereiten miteinander zu bringen
und das ist ihm alles auf Zeit und und
da spielen jetzt unsere
Waffenlieferungen mit sehen da hat
glaube ich der Kanzler auch recht genau
an diesem Punkt wenn er sagt was immer
wir hier machen muss immer gut
abgestimmt sein wo man auf ein
Netzwerken
die sie militärisch gestellt haben würde
ich sagen dass ich finde das ist darauf
eine
politische Antwort gibt und die finde
ich nicht schwer zu beantworten
politisch ist klar was wir machen wir
wollen der Ukraine helfen
ukrainisches Territorium möglichst das
ganze ukrainische Territorium das
besetzt ist zu befreien warum tun wir
das zum einen weil es sich um ein
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffs
Angriffskrieg handelt zum anderen aber
auch weil uns klar sein muss dass
alles was am Ende von russischer Seite
als Erfolg gewertet werden würde uns
unsicherer macht das muss auch mit
bedacht werden bei allen diplomatischen
Lösungen die sie anmahnen
wir werden in Europa nicht friedlicher
leben in einer Situation in der am Ende
aus Moskauer Sicht eigentlich gilt die
Operation hat sich gelohnt die
spezialoperation hat sich gelohnt so
können wir das machen so wollen wir
Europa jetzt ordnen wenn wir irgendwo
demnächst vielleicht nicht mehr Ukraine
wenn wir eben irgendwo ein Stück
Territorium sehen von dem wir finden das
gehört uns dann werden wir uns das
militärisch holen das wollen wir nicht
deshalb ist glaube ich das politische
Ziel vollkommen klar es muss diskutiert
werden wie es militärisch erreicht
werden kann ich muss ganz offen zugeben
dass ich ihren Einwand das wird zu viel
über Waffen diskutiert nicht ganz
verstehe aus Sicht eines Zivilisten
nicht ganz nicht ganz nein aus Sicht
eines Zivilisten nicht ganz verstehe
weil sie eingangsargumentiert haben
vieles sei ja auch sozusagen aus dem
Weltraum zu beobachten es gehe um
Ausbildung um Aufklärung das verstehe
ich alles nur alle Ausbildung und alle
Aufklärung und alle Informationen mit
denen die USA die Ukraine versorgen
können wird
aus meiner leiden haften Sicht ohne
Bewaffnung und ohne ausreichend
Bewaffnung der Ukraine nicht nützen wäre
die Ukraine nicht von Anfang an und
nicht zuerst von Deutschland sondern
zuerst von anderen
deutlich bewaffnet worden dann gäbe es
die Ukraine heute als unabhängigen Staat
nicht mehr und das ist etwas was wir
glaube ich immer mit bedenken müssen
ich hätte auch gegenrufe aber vielleicht
können Sie wahrscheinlich überhaupt
nicht in ihrem Ruf nach wachenlieferung
leiser werden möchte das geht ja nicht
so um den Ruf es geht ja ich denke wir
gucken auf die Fakten wir alle gucken
auf die Fakten wie analysieren die
Situation und genau das beobachten wir
dass die Ausbildung und natürlich das
Zusammenspiel von sehr vielen Faktoren
genau zu den Erfolgen führt die die
Ukraine zu verzeichnen hat und da möchte
ich Ihnen auch sehr widersprechen indem
dass die Waffen jetzt nicht die
maßgebliche Rolle spielen die Waffen
spielen die maßgebliche Rolle wenn die
Ukraine genug Waffen hat und das Kampf
der Kampfgeist der ukrainischen Armee
ist kaum zu übersehen auch der Menschen
in der Ukraine des Land zu verteidigen
denke ich dass die Waffen an der Stelle
wirklich der entscheidende Punkt sind
und auch die Geschlossenheit in dieser
Frage
zwei zwei antwortpunkte sozusagen zwei
Richtungen
die Ukraine hat jetzt den Durchbruch
geschafft den Paukenschlag durch die
Kombination von Panzern
luft-dienstlichen Kenntnis das ist nicht
abstrakt das sind ganz konkrete
Fähigkeiten die ausgewertet in Echtzeit
ausgewertet werden müssen weiter
vermitteln und Angriffe übersetzt werden
müssen das ist der Punkt wenn es nur um
die Waffengänge werden ja die Russen
schon 10 mal Sieger weil die haben ja
viel mehr ich will nur sagen der Grund
der Waffen Menge ist es nicht sondern es
ist die Qualität und das Zusammenspiel
und das sagte ich ja das wird über das
Rammstein Format gemacht ein kurzer Satz
der Kritik hier noch dass wir das so
schlecht machen mit unseren Lieferung
das hat nichts mit dem strategischen
Ansatz das abzustimmen zu tun nicht das
ist einfach nur ein sonderaspekt
sozusagen der deutschen Administration
das nicht vernünftig auf die Reihe zu
kriegen jetzt kommen wir auf einen
anderen wichtigen Punkt der im Grunde
auch auch meinem Nachbarn sozusagen in
die Hände spielt was wir in dieser
ganzen Diskussion nicht bereden und was
auch politisch geredet werden müsste
welchen Nutzen streben wir an welchen
Schaden nehmen wir in Kauf und gibt es
Grenzen für diese Solidarität das ist
ein Thema das kann man nicht so blieben
unterschwellig irgendwo in welchen
kammerchen Bedenken darüber muss man
reden und das lese ich nicht und das
höre ich auch nicht mehr Debatte und das
ist der Mangel den ich benennen möchte
ja dass wir uns da nicht ehrlich genug
gemacht haben in Deutschland aber Herr
pohlmeier kommt natürlich noch einmal
und jetzt auch mit dieser Situation dass
eine ging das andere abzuwägen die
Waffenlieferung
Kontrapunkt einfach setzen wollen ich
habe der eingangs mit den
Waffenlieferungen das sehr moderat
formuliert ich habe große Zweifel dass
das der richtige Weg ist ich habe auch
das Gefühl dass wir aufpassen müssen
dass wir uns nicht von einem gewissen
Wunschdenken jetzt leiten lassen wenn
wir es um eine militärische Wende geht
was wirklich passiert wissen wir doch
gar nicht ich glaube in diesem
Zusammenhang dass die wenn Thomas
Friedman in der New York Times schreibt
die einzige Chance für die Ukraine den
Krieg zu gewinnen ist wenn die NATO
reingeht
das ist immer noch ganz stark mein
Gefühl dass das gelten würde und dann
muss man sich eben dafür rüber
unterhalten ob es das ist was man in
irgendeiner Form in Kauf nehmen würde
ich ich wir sind uns hier eigentlich am
Tisch das das unerträglich ist was
Präsident Putin gemacht hat unerträglich
das ist ohne jeden Zweifel die Frage ist
wie kann man dieses verdammte grauen
beenden und ich glaube dass wir
wir müssen deswegen trotz dieser ganz
dieses gräuels und der Katastrophe
Russlands dazu kommen dass wir es geht
um Frieden und nicht um Sieg gegen
Russland das muss man sich ganz klar
machen das hat nichts mit Sympathie für
die russische Führung zu tun das hat was
damit zu tun dass man einen Ausgleich
erreichen muss der sehr angerecht ist so
Definition und ich glaube ich das und da
glaube ich dass die dass diese Debatte
um dass man jetzt dass wir jetzt glauben
Mensch wenn du ein bisschen mehr Waffen
liefern dann können wir es gewinnen
was mich wundert weil wir stürzen uns in
der Tat auf bestimmte Fakten und
wir dürfen nicht alles alles in Frage
stellen weil genau alles in Frage zu
stellen das ist das Ziel von der
Propaganda und das ist das oberste Ziel
von der Propaganda wir können auch nicht
sagen dass wir nicht wissen was passiert
ist wenn wir offensichtlich auch Bilder
Videomaterial von der ukrainischen Armee
haben von befreiten Regionen wir haben
Bilder wo Menschen aus den Häusern
rausgehen und die ukrainische Armee auf
den auf der Straße begrüßen deswegen
finde ich zu sagen wir wissen nicht was
passiert das ist nicht ganz richtig weil
wir wissen genau
wirklich ganz genau wir kennen Putins
Kriegsziel weil er das ganz offen
formulierte
Ziel ist die Zerstörung der Ukraine
sogar die Auslöschung der Ukraine als
Nation und ich kann Forderungen nach
Diplomatie verstehen ich kann Gruppe
nach einem Ausgleich verstehen aber man
muss dann schon auch die Frage stellen
dürfen Ausgleich womit worin besteht der
Ausgleich und deshalb
gibt es aus meiner Sicht zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt in der jetzigen Lage keine
Möglichkeit in Verhandlungen zu einem
Ende des Krieges zu kommen
das ist natürlich schwierig und komplex
ist ja klar die Russen sind schwierige
fanden das Partner trotzdem wird es
darum gehen müssen es wird darum gehen
müssen zurück zumindest zwei zu den
Fragen die dort formuliert sind sie
sagen das sind für die ich würde immer
sagen ein Trick russland hat den Einsatz
fürs Tod die die Putin hat gesagt Minz
ist tot das putin ist überhaupt nicht
daran interessiert über Minz zu
verhandeln ja aber hätte ich sogar eine
Frage entschuldigung aber was lässt sie
glauben
tatsächlich welche Indikatoren lassen
Sie glauben dass das funktionieren wird
das Minsk 2134 funktionieren wird sie
sprechen jetzt von ganz konkret von
mindestens zwei was lässt sie glauben
was mich glauben das Problem ist was die
Alternative ist das ist das Problem an
der Geschichte die Frage ist
durch die Veränderung des Krieges wird
es zu einer Eskalation führen die uns
alle in den Abgrund reißt am Ende ich
bin jetzt keine Verschwörungstheorie der
da aber ist das was ist die Alternative
es muss ich sage nicht dass es einfach
ist das ja klar es komplexes ist klar
aber wir müssen vielleicht
Zwischenschritte finden vielleicht
müssen wir sagen okay bestimmte Ziele
werden ausgeklammert von den kriegsam
wie zum Beispiel Atomkraftwerke oder
zivile Strukturen was jetzt die Russen
ja angefangen haben zu den Erfolgen des
Wochenendes gehört ja leider auch die
Tragik das jetzt zivile Infrastruktur
von den Russen bombardiert wird also ähm
ja ja
natürlich sagen an dieser Stelle glaube
ich kaum sie nicht zusammen das müssen
wir jetzt einfach akzeptieren deswegen
müssen wir wirklich noch einsam Einsatz
sagen kann das was mich stört und was
ich nicht akzeptiere als Staatsbürger in
diesem Land ist dass Diplomaten
hier gewählt haben sagen mit den Russen
kann man nicht verhandeln und kann man
nicht erkennen 20 Minuten telefonieren
meine Frage vorweg genau nach über zwei
Monaten gibt es wieder einen direkten
Kontakt also gibt es zumindest eine
Person in Deutschland auch wenn er jetzt
eine Faktor kein Diplomat ist aber
Politiker der glaubt reden bringt was
macron hat übrigens auch am Wochenende
mit ihm telefoniert der Bundeskanzler
redet mit dem russischen Präsidenten
aber nicht ich glaube wenn wir Ihnen
jetzt hier sitzen hätten und ihn fragen
würden glauben sie an Verhandlungen zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt in Russland würde er
sagen nein warum telefoniert er mit dem
russischen Präsidenten unter anderem aus
dem Grund um den russischen Präsidenten
mit bestimmten
Tatsachen zu konfrontieren von denen er
fürchtet dass er die nicht bereit ist
wahrzunehmen das ist immer wieder der
Versuch von westlicher Seite auch von
macron
Putin mit der Realität zu konfrontieren
das ist notwendig und natürlich muss
gesprochen werden
dagegen bin ich auch gar nicht wende
mich nur gegen die ich würde sagen
Illusion dass man zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
einen Ausgleich finden kann Ausgleich
das suggeriert ja es gibt da irgendwo
einen Punkt zwischen den beiden
Positionen zwischen der ukrainischen und
der russischen Position auf die man sich
jetzt verständigen kann und dann wird es
gut da müssen sie nun wirklich sie
sprechen ja russisch da müssen sie
wirklich nur das russische Fernsehen
schauen um zu verstehen das ist diesen
Punkt zu Zeit nicht gibt und das Problem
dass ich mit dieser Forderung habe ist
dass diese Forderung
ja zusammen geht mit einem russischen
Wirtschaftskrieg der gegen
den Westen geführt wird der auch gegen
Deutschland geführt wird mit der Waffe
Energie und der natürlich in den
kommenden Wochen und Monaten die
Diskussion in Deutschland auch stark
beeinflussen wird also zusammen wird
kommen die Forderung nach
wie auch immer gearteten Verhandlungen
mit einer schwierigen Situation in
Deutschland selbst und das spielt das
würde ich so hart sagen das spielt dem
Kreml in die Hände wo wir am Ende landen
da würde ich ganz gerne noch einen
Schlusskurve machen aber ich möchte das
Kapitel der Waffenlieferung noch nicht
ganz schließen auch Tele wenn Sie ein
bisschen zurückhaltender sind aber
bringen sie jetzt doch noch mal wenn wir
uns das jetzt betrachten da kann auch
gleich noch mal Herr Brüssel was ein
bisschen zur ampelarithmetik und zur
Ampel
Melodie sagen aber man hat jetzt so den
Eindruck es werden nochmal die
Waffengattungen durchgespielt jetzt sind
sie der einzige Militär am Tisch und
jetzt müssen Sie uns auch wirklich dann
da ganz gefühlvoll helfen was wäre für
die Ukraine jetzt nützlich bei der Art
und Weise wie wir Frontlinie dazu
mindestens durch internationale Karten
bei BBC World und sonst beobachten
können ja das spielen wir tatsächlich
wir international der Westen seit Anfang
an durch wenn man schaut dann ging es am
Anfang und panzerbrechende Waffen darum
um auch Luftabwehr um großen erst gar
nicht mit ihrer Luftwaffe dort zur
Wirkung kommen zu lassen das passiert
auch vorher in der Ausbildung der Leute
mit das ging dann weiter als es in die
artilleriekrieg ging in die
Unterstützung mit hochleistungsfähiger
Artillerie die aus vielen Ländern auch
aus unserer aus Deutschland gekommen ist
wo wir auch in der Ausbildung mitmachen
weil wir haben es ja erlebt zum Teil
dass dann mancher Haubitzen schon nach
ein paar Wochen außer Gefecht waren weil
sie übermäßig genutzt werden das war
immer dieses ausbildungsargument das ist
ganz wichtig gerade wenn der Krieg
anhält dass man das machen kann und
gerade jetzt hat die Ukraine gezeichnet
welcher Brillanz sie inzwischen die
Heimat der amerikanischen Raketenwerfer
nutzen kann um das zu machen also genau
das findet ja eigentlich statt und
deswegen sage ich es auch auch deshalb
ist unsere Panzer wir beide unterirdisch
weil sie in viele Aspekte hat natürlich
und da haben die Ukraine mit Ihren
Anfragen recht müssen sie ihre Truppen
beschützt nach vorne bringen das ist
etwas was der Marder könnte wenn
erfahren würde das ist sagen so ein
kleines Apache Süd dass ich mit
dranhänge das ist eben bei uns auch
schlechte Technologie die auch in
Deutschland nicht geklappt hat also das
das sind so Schwierigkeiten die sind
aber das macht man tatsächlich
international man schaut auf die Option
und versucht der Ukraine all das zu
geben was was erforderlich ist und das
sollten wir auch helfen
die jetzt luftmäßig ist der Gepard
stellt also ich konnte damals gar nicht
verstehen dass die Bundeswehr ihnen
aufgegeben hat der stellt Eisen in die
Luft also das ist wirklich so eine hohe
Schussfrequenz dass da nichts
durchfliegen kann das ist für die
Ukraine richtig wichtig das Problem ist
nur wir bringen keine Munition ran das
das muss natürlich auch gelöst werden
aber Schlusspunkt in der kleinen
Waffenkunde Herr Tele wenn sie noch
erlauben also der Leopard 2 ist das
jetzt das sozusagen das Wording was
insbesondere in der ampelverteidigungs-
und Außenpolitiker jetzt jeden Tag
benutzen macht das Sinn
der Leopard 2 macht natürlich
waffentechnisch Sinn ob er dahin kommt
wird aber letztlich auch an unseren
Verbündeten liegen die das gut abstimmen
das heißt also die Amerikaner werden
letztlich die Frage beantworten werden
ob wir da ob wir den Leo dorthin werfen
ich gebe natürlich auch zu bedenken dass
für uns ja doch aggressive und
bedrohliche Russland muss auch aus
Deutschland heraus verteidigt werden
können die gleichen die jetzt hurra
rufen die Waffen alle da wegzugeben das
sind ja die gleichen die vorher
verhindert haben dass wir diese Waffen
bekommen haben also dass wir so wenig
geben können ist ja genau sozusagen
ursächlich mit denen verbunden die jetzt
sagen weg damit also dich hier ist hier
ist wirklich eine Falle in diesem Thema
die sollte die sollte man schon beachten
das mit so Herrn Rössler und seiner
Ampel dass er Thiele sagt ich mache das
jetzt besonders salopp der Amerikaner
bestimmt was wir schicken dürfen
insbesondere dieses den Leoparden 2 das
bringt uns jetzt das bedeutet ja im
Grunde genommen dass dieses Mantra von
keiner Alleingänge auch irgendwie was
bedeutet das Mantra bedeutet was ich
würde nur vorausschicken den einen Punkt
dass ich das nicht für eine reine Ampel
oder deutsche Diskussion halte wir haben
gerade heute mehrere Stellungnahmen
wieder gehört aus Kiew wo gebeten wurde
um den Leoparden also ich glaube das was
wir in Deutschland sehen was wir in
Berlin sind spiegelt eigentlich das was
an Forderungen aus Kiew kommt und ja der
Bundeskanzler hat immer wieder davon
gesprochen dass Deutschland keine
Alleingänge unternimmt ich glaube was er
damit meint ist glaube ich die enge
Abstimmung vor allen Dingen mit den USA
und noch spezieller seine Abstimmung mit
dem US-Präsidenten das ist richtig die
USA liefern bisher auch der gleichen
nicht wir hören aber Signale und ich
glaube die kommen auch in der Ampel an
von amerikanischer Seite die zumindest
vermuten lassen dass die USA ist
vielleicht gar nicht verkehrt finden
wenn die Europäer jetzt auch mal
vorangehen und ich wäre nicht überrascht
wenn sich das in den nächsten Tagen zwei
Wochen konkretisiert und wenn Signale
tatsächlich aus Washington kämen die
sagen an uns scheitert es nicht wenn ihr
es jetzt richtig findet
dieses Gerät zu schicken ist das nichts
was jetzt gegen die gegen die
bündnissolidarität verstoßen
SPD Außenpolitiker wie Michael Roth sich
hinsetzt Vorsitzender des Ausschusses
und sagt ich gebe mal ein Interview und
sag mal lass uns doch mal jetzt reden
lass uns doch nicht nur sagen hier kein
Alleingang sondern reden das kommt ja
nicht von ungefähr Stellungnahmen zum
Beispiel von der amerikanischen
Botschaft darin in Berlin die das
zumindest die das zumindest vermuten
lassen wobei ich das was Michael Roth
sagt oder was agnesstrack Marie Agnes
stark Zimmermann die Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses sagt oder tun
ich glaube es gibt einfach innerhalb der
Ampel in allen Parteien eigentlich
Politiker die finden wir könnten mehr
machen und die aus der Ampel heraus
Druck auf den Kanzler ausüb nun muss man
allerdings auch sehen dass es in der
Ampel wiederum andere Stimmen auch gibt
und das ist ein
ein Kampf innerhalb innerhalb dieser
Koalition ist und zum Teil sogar
innerhalb der Parteien wie weit man
jetzt gehen sollen wie schnell man
vorangehen soll und das richtet sich
natürlich alles auf den Kanzler der
unter diesem Erwartungsdruck eben steht
letztlich von beiden Seiten der
Tempomacher sein könnte aber davon kein
Gebrauch macht
ein Problem finde nur um das zu sagen
ist dass der Kanzler das aus meiner
Sicht nicht ausreichend erklärt zum
Beispiel auch jetzt wieder nicht
ausreichend erklärt ich finde ich finde
als Begründung diesen nun wirklich
vielfachen bitten aus Kiew vorläufig
nicht zu entsprechen nur zu sagen wir
Unternehmen keine Alleingänge nicht
befriedigend man könnte es ja vielleicht
erklären es gibt vielleicht Gründe die
wir nicht kennen aber der Bundeskanzler
teilt sie nicht mit uns Frau Berger
musste da am Wochenende Frau
da sich dies an dies und jenes dann
anhören und die Frage ist wie groß ist
der Frust bei den Kollegas dieser Welt
wenn Sie diese Debatte anschauen in
Deutschland es ist natürlich also ich
finde Annalena Weber Wehrburg alleine
die Gäste da sie nach Kiew gefahren
jetzt eine große Geste und dass wir
weiterhin im also dass die die
Regierungen im Gespräch bleiben das ist
ein ein wichtiges Signal
wie frustriert die Menschen sind oder
wie die Reaktion sein kann es ist
natürlich dadurch dass wir sehr viele
Einschätzungen hören das mehr möglich
ist und trotzdem das nicht passiert
da bin ich total auf ihrer Seite dass da
an der Kommunikation einfach mangelt das
ist nicht erklärt wird warum und ein
Eindruck entsteht dass Deutschland nicht
möchte und dann solche Statements Folgen
von der von der SPD zum Beispiel von
Kevin kühners der der meinte dass
Russland
irrational handeln konnte und wir noch
größere also das andere Städte
angegriffen werden können das stellt bei
mir sich die Frage als Bürgerin in einem
Bundesrepublik Deutschland was sind wir
denn bereit in Frage in Kauf zu nehmen
das zurück auf ihre Statements auch zu
führen was sind wir denn bereit in Kauf
zu nehmen das sind ja Menschen in der
Ukraine über die wir sprechen
und ich denke dass mit den Menschen
gesprochen wird dass
Annalena behrburg in die Ukraine fährt
und mit Herrn Kollege spricht das ist
das ist ein gutes Zeichen und jetzt
natürlich hoffen wir dass die Daten auch
Folgen ja es bringt uns jetzt zu unserer
Schlussrunde wir sind sozusagen schon
wieder recht weit vorangeschritten wenn
wir quasi Herr Thiele hatte das hier
eingangsformuliert dass wir in Jahren
denken wenn wir das jetzt mal als
Prämisse runterlegen Herr pohlmeier wenn
ich quasi mal bei den nicht Militär ist
jetzt beginnen darf wenn wir jetzt
überlegen wie ein Szenario für ein
Kriegsende aussehen könnte welches wäre
denn
aus dieser Zeitachse heraus wo wir uns
jetzt befinden für Sie wahrscheinlich
oder wishful thinking
ich rede jetzt als nicht Militär
sozusagen und sonst und deswegen erlaube
ich mir zusammen was mich antreibt in
meiner Arbeit ich beschäftige mit der
Abrüstung von Atomwaffen seit 30 Jahren
mein Erlebnis ist der Fall der Berliner
Mauer hätte ich mir nie vorstellen
können weil jenseits meiner Vorstellung
habe ich erlebt war sozusagen aus dem
Nichts ich hätte mir nie vorstellen
können dass er ein internationalen
Vertrag gibt der Atomwaffen verbietet
das ist erreicht worden bei den
Vereinten Nationen Deutschland ist nicht
Mitglied ich bin auch hier der Meinung
den Krieg was den Krieg zu werden zu
sagen wir hören auf von russischer Seite
dauert 5 Minuten ich sage jetzt mal ganz
überspitzt es muss ein Dreh geben
Putin dazu zu bringen damit aufzuhören
dass ich weiß nicht welcher das ist wir
müssen alles dafür tun dass wir das
erreichen und dass wir Leute finden die
das Moderieren daran glaube ich dass es
die entscheidende Frage damit es nicht
zur Katastrophe für die Ukraine
zuallererst und dann vielleicht auch für
uns kommen welcher Dreh wäre das dass
wir von heute auf morgen ich denke dass
sehr entscheidend ist weiterhin
solidarisch mit Ukraine zu sein
Unterstützung zu bieten und auch
Unterstützung zu liefern im Sinne von
Waffen im Sinne von Ausbildung das alles
was schon passiert nur intensiver und
das besser zu kommunizieren und ich
denke wir sind wirklich jetzt an eine
sehr wichtigen Etappe angelangt dass es
für Russland für die russische Führung
sehr kritisch werden kann
und als jemand der sozusagen die
verschiedenen Schauplätze auch kennt und
weiß auch dass Deutschland glaubwürdig
sein möchte weiterhin
Kriegsende können wir irgendwas
beitragen ich glaube dass der Dreh
einfach nur der sein wird eine Situation
herbeizuführen in der aus russischer
Sicht die Weiterführung des Krieges
gefährlicher ist
als die Beendigung des Krieges und aus
meiner Sicht führt der Weg dahin nur
über eine starke Unterstützung der
Ukraine eben auch mit war und genau
dieser dreh das ist kein Sinn mehr macht
einen Krieg vorzuführen können Sie sich
auch dahinter versammeln Herr tilge ich
hätte tatsächlich zwei Dinge einzuziehen
für Ihre nächste Sendung dann gleich mit
bottom up wir müssen uns so stark halten
in Deutschland dass wir die
Unterstützung weiter halten können das
scheint mir zu wenig nachdenken zu sein
Nummer zwei der Weg zum Stopp führt über
China und da versagen wir bisher da sind
wir zu greifen kurz das wäre sozusagen
mein Vorschlag für die nächste Sendung
oder eine nächste Sendung in der Tat das
ist immer ein guter Punkt in diese
Richtung zu schauen meine Dame meine
Herrin darf mich ganz herzlich bedanken
für ihre engagierte Debatte die uns noch
einmal im Schritt weitergebracht hat
meine Damen und Herren auch bei ihnen
vielen Dank dass sie ihre Zeit mit uns
geteilt haben Blick auf morgen Thema für
morgen zwischen Krieg und Rezession wie
kommt Europa durch die Krise das wollen
wir uns etwas näher vornehmen ich
bedanke mich und wünsche gute
Information bei Phoenix
[Musik]